I was digging around in old photos and I
came across this one which is about 10
years old it's from when I was teaching
at Marist College in Poughkeepsie New
York and you can see just behind it this
river that this gigantic head was fished
out of and it was kind of a mystery for
a while what is this is it a prank is it
some sort of giant statue that somehow
got damaged went awry and you can
actually look it up online to find out
about it but they fished it out of the
Hudson River and they plonked it right
down in front of the if I remember
correctly The Boathouse Marist had a
rowing team and it was such a great site
that I couldn't resist taking a picture
of it look at those Soulful eyes so
caption contest 10 best entries here
they are the first one and you can guess
of course that there's going to be a lot
of broken face broken nose jokes this is
probably one of the best I was going to
make a Caesar Borgia joke but I felt
that would be a little too on the nose
you know he was known for having a big
old nose and his statues nose is all
busted up uh here's another one
similarly playing off of the nose and
it's a pun that's almost painful to read
you don't want to know or actually want
to know what he knows right playing off
of a homonymy I think that's the way
it's pronounced of nose meaning the
thing on your face and knows as in
what somebody has knowledge of so this
is a pretty good one right
here's another one uh playing off of a
classic proverb broke off my nose and
Chin to spite my face of course the old
proverb is cutting off your nose to
spite your face but this is uh witty one
nonetheless
and here's another one uh playing off as
you see a lot of these are playing off
of classic references what had two
eyebrows in the morning one knows in the
afternoon and neither in the evening
this of course is a reference to the
Sphinx's riddle to Oedipus in Oedipus
Rex and the answer is of course this
poor face that got all of these things
knocked off of it
uh we go on with another one that
doesn't at least mention the nose
although I suppose it does imply it
doesn't it I might have took it on the
chin the Chin's all damaged but I'm
thankful I don't have to smell the
Hudson anymore I suppose because the
nose is no longer sniffing things and
the Hudson can be a little stinky at
times so now we're finished up with nose
and shin references and I I like this
one too art is never finished until
times invisible hand has made its Mark
and it's not just the time but also the
flow of the river so kind of a rich
reference there that you're getting
um here is the the next one and I I got
a real kick out of this imagine what
phrenologists will say his character is
through no fault of his own this poor
statue with a giant head got his face
all busted up and phrenologists would
undoubtedly say bad things about him
because of that
um then we enter into another theme
let's call it thrasymicus after a
conversation with Socrates now the funny
thing is that through simicus is the one
who would seem to be threatening
Socrates who's already
ugly with violence and it's uh sort of
assumed that either Socrates or Socrates
buddies beat the crap out of
thrasymachus and that's why his face is
all busted up here we get one that's
referencing me a little bit oh this is
me after leaving a stupid comment on
this channel and having been dragged
under the Keel I'm slowly learning my
limitations of course that's figurative
nobody's actually beating anybody else
up on this video channel but uh it's
kind of a a witty joke nonetheless and
now we get to the final joke and I think
this is for me this is the best and it's
a reference that we had a little bit
before about times invisible hand now we
get to Ozymandias by Percy blice Shelley
once you are done despairing could you
help me find my legs and so yeah of
course you're supposed to there's the
base of a pillar saying look upon my
mighty works and look upon my works you
mighty and despair right so after you're
finished looking at this head that's
been fished out of the Hudson that
perhaps is emblematic for all of our
great projects can you help me find the
parts that are missing and it's a good
joke and I
maybe get more of a kick out of it than
I should I don't know I'll be interested
to see what you make of it in the
comments so you want to get in on the
next caption contest just you know stay
tuned to the channel you're probably
going to want to click the notifications
button that that Bell right and you'll
see the pics posted in the community tab
on my YouTube channel and then you can
let it rip and say what you want the
best 10 captions get into caption
contests and we'll be doing these
through the rest of the year and Beyond
so that is a wrap